talked a bit about love but
let me it's it's fun to ask somebody
like you who uh
can effectively from at least
neuroscience perspective
disassemble some of these romantic
notions but what do you make of romantic
love
well why do human beings seem to fall in
at least at least a bunch of 80s hair
bands have written about it
uh is that a nice feature to have
is that a bug what is it well i i'm
really happy
that i fell in love i wouldn't want it
any other way
um but i would say is that you the
person speaking or the neuroscientist
well i me that's me the person smiling
but uh i would say
as a neuroscientist babies are born
not able to regulate their own body
budgets because their brains aren't
fully wired yet
when you
feed a baby when you cuddle a baby when
you
everything you do with a baby impacts
that baby's body budget and helps to
wire that baby's body budget
um has to wire that baby's brain to
manage eventually her own body budget to
some extent
that's the basis biologically of
attachment
humans evolved as a species
to be socially dependent meaning
you cannot manage your body budget
on your own without a tax
that eventually you pay many years later
in terms of some metabolic illness right
loneliness when you break up with
someone that you love
or you lose them right it you feel like
it's gonna kill you
but it doesn't but loneliness will kill
you
it will kill you approximately you know
what is it seven years earlier i can't
remember exactly the exact number it's
it's actually in the web notes to um
seven and a half lessons but um
social isolation loneliness will kill
you earlier than you would otherwise die
and the reason why
is that you're not you didn't evolve to
manage your nervous system on your own
and when you do
you pay a little tax and that tax
accrues very slightly
over time over a long period of time so
that by the time
you're in you know middle-aged or a
little older
you are more likely to die sooner from
some metabolic illness from heart
disease
from diabetes from depression um you're
more likely to develop alzheimer's
disease i mean it's
the it you know it takes a long time for
that tax to accrue
um but it does so yes i think it's a
good
thing for people to um to fall in love
but i think the funny view of it is that
uh
it's clear that humans need the social
attachment
to uh what is it manage their nervous
system is
as as you're describing and the reason
you want to stay with somebody for
a long time is so you don't have is the
novelties very costly for
uh for well now you're mixing now you're
mixing things now you're you know
no you have to decide whether but what i
would say is when you
lose someone you love you um it feels
like you've lost a part of you
and that's because you have you've lost
someone
who was contributing to your body budget
we are the caretakers of one another's
nervous systems like it or not
and um out of that comes
very deep feelings of attachment some of
which
are romantic love
you